one division had a lot of ground to
cover in its finale
what with the scrolls and the child
death and explaining what you're the
scarlet witch means of it all
among the episodes biggest twist alluded
to in the post-credits scene from the
week before was a climactic round of
rock'em soccer robots in the sky above
westview the showdown between the
various versions of the vision
both played by paul bettany was a final
confrontation in the tradition of
marvel's best third act
donny brooks it was all made possible by
director heywood
and his crack team of sword scientists
frankensteins who audiences had
recently learned spent the last five
years pulling vision's body apart
and putting it back together the result
was what we'll call white vision
the soulless zero percent mind stone
shell of a synthesis who
wait for it pales in comparison to the
original while the vision that audiences
had spent the last eight episodes with
was revealed to be a construct of
wonders imagination and abilities
this was a repurposed corpse of the hero
first introduced back in age of ultron
minus the personality and appreciation
for paprika
white vision comes straight from the
comics where he premiered under similar
circumstances
during the events of the vision quest
storyline back in the 80s when regular
vision was disassembled by unscrupulous
folks his reassembled form came out of
their proverbial oven without emotions
or colour saturation
what's happened next might offer us some
clues as to what we can expect from this
the mcus laid this in a long line of
tortured heroes by the end of one
division's final episode a conflict
between the scarlet witch's idealized
version of her dead beloved and the cold
and feeling reality had been brought to
a close
the weapon of choice and the conflict
was naturally logic
well first skull lasers but then logic
after that rescue vision determines that
his adversary is a component pieces of
his old body
reassembled but robbed of memories
concluding that he can't truly be vision
without the experiences that moulded him
west view vision jacks into the
monochrome synthazoid's brain
implanting everything that the character
have been through so far
shuri's diagnostics the fight with
ultron the battles leading up to the
sokovia records
and his death at the giant purple hands
of thanos importantly we don't see any
of the memories of his time in westview
what we do see is a time-honored visual
shorthand for a bad comic book character
turning good
white vision's eyes change color going
from what we'll call prismatic glitter
bomb
to paul bettany's baby blues
white vision proclaims and he jets off
through a skylight in true superhero
fashion
also totally on brand for the avenger he
doesn't bother to ask if anyone would
like some help cleaning up
after his brain lasers made a mess
that's the culture of exceptionalism for
you
after the dust has settled viewers are
left wondering what happened to
haywood's secret weapon
it can be assumed that we'll be seeing
him again in the future but in what form
since a truly recuperated vision would
have gone straight to one decide
it seems like a fair guess that the
colourless version of him still isn't
running at his full capacity
not even in the time it takes wonder to
set up shop in a charming woodland cabin
in the middle of nowhere
where he could have gone whether he's
back in sword custody and crucially
whether he's aware of the events
depicted in endgame
remains to be seen by the point in the
comics when the vision had fully
recovered his personality
wonder had moved on to newer more
exciting personal breakdowns
as alluded to in the second one division
post-credit scene
which saw her focus more on magic and
the desperate cries of her disappeared
kids
than on trying to reinstall her missing
husband's old operating system
it'll likely be some time before we get
concrete answers to the question of
business fate
in the meantime all we can do is turn
our voices as one to the minds behind
the marvel cinematic universe
and say please please don't break our
hearts again
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite mcu tv shows and movies
are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one